hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we're talking about
political polarization where it comes
from and why it seems to be more now
than it was in the past you know I'm
always someone who is a little bit
skeptical when people point to the
present day and some feature of it
whether it's economic or political or
whatever and say it's very different now
than it ever used to be that's very
difficult to say objectively right
because we all experience the world
differently when we're 20 years old 50
years old 80 years old and we change no
doubt so it seems to us that the world
is changing in different ways but it's
hard to be objective about it
nevertheless I do kind of buy the idea
that political polarization has
increased in the sense that there's sort
of an assorting of people it's very
least in the US but I think it's a
broader phenomenon than that into a set
of alignments on different issues that
you might not think are necessarily
connected and nevertheless people are
sorting themselves into tribes and this
is not a correct or incorrect thing
maybe this is a good thing I don't know
but it seems to be there and we want to
ask well why did that happen in a way
that there seem to be more of a
continuum in the past so today I'm
talking to Ezra Klein who is the name
that most of you I'm sure know as Ferg
has a famous podcast of his own Ezra and
I sort of heard of each other got to
know each other a very tiny bit way back
in the early days of blogging you know I
started my blog in 2004 preposterous
universe Ezra was writing at wonk blog
and Pentagon back in the day now of
course he's the co-founder and and I
don't know what exactly was title is
head editor of voxcom which has become a
little bit controversial I guess because
people like controversy I'm happy to say
that I love voxcom
I don't always agree with what they're
doing but I love the philosophy of
explainers right of giving you the
background for why things are true so
anything dealing with politics is going
to engender controversy but that's okay
we got to do it I'm a believer that
understanding the political world is
very important
so this podcast is not about saying
who's right who's wrong but trying to
understand the forces that have
increased polarization in the modern
world is there something we can do about
it should there be something we can do
about it is it inevitable is technology
causing it or is it something that is a
little bit more contingent and perhaps
reversible remember you can support the
podcast by becoming a patreon supporter
on patreon.com slash Sean M Carroll and
you don't have to support on patreon
them I don't mind one way or the other
but it's a nice thing to do and also it
gets you add to free versions of the
podcast Plus every month I try to answer
a bunch of questions and it asked me
anything that can be a lot of fun people
ask really good questions and that's
become a great tradition so patreon.com
slash Sean M Carroll and with that let's
go
[Music]
as for clim welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm thrilled to be here
so Dumas guest you've ever had well no
well you know there's no such thing as a
dumb guest but the most math illiterate
if I if I recall correctly you're a
blogger at Pentagon is that correct is
that yes that is right I am I'm Jesse
Taylor's understudy you know we all
start somewhere did you ever have a
vision of what blogging was going to
become like back in the days did you
think that today it's some sort of it's
either been absorbed by the media or it
is the media I'm not quite sure which
way to say it yeah and now it's funny
now because a lot of original bloggers
run media organizations and user
platforms to be nostalgic about how they
can't seem to bring blogging back and
how it all got killed but no I will
sometimes get this an analysis will get
put on my career that I've been making
these very strategic moves from the very
beginning I get into an in the media and
people forget how absurd the idea was
originally the blogging would ever get
you any kind of job it was not not just
the word blog there's no other thing
that has the blah sounds like blog right
yeah it's phonetically - scoffing I like
that but also it initially was hated by
journalists it was it it it rose up as
part of a critique of how the media did
its work
so the idea when I was a freshman in
college starting a blog yeah but that
would somehow ever lead to journalism
you I would have laughed at you
and so it's actually one of these things
where a lot of other people saw earlier
than I did that I might end up in
journalism because even well into my
blogging career those two worlds just
seemed so different from each other that
the idea of bridging them seemed a bit
absurd they were back in the day but you
know I do have nostalgia's back for
those days my wife Jennifer and I met
because we read each other's blogs so no
kidding good things can happen oh my god
the most beautiful blog story of them
all it's pretty good
and our engagement was announced in
nature the scientific journal so but now
you're you're all growing up in writing
books there's some steps in between but
we'll skip those but you have a book out
called why we're polarized is that right
yes
first question I have to ask as a fellow
book author is how much discussion went
in with you and your publisher about why
we're polarized versus why we are
polarized your contraction in there
zero zero you know they just went for it
you just suggested zero they did not
maybe they would not have dare to
suggest why we are polarized to me all
right
we went through a bunch of I'm a big
believer that the only words that matter
in anything of a headline so at Vox I
have a rule that if you write a piece
which is what we do or a video or a
podcast any of it you have to come up
with ten headline options because you'll
people spend all this time on the
underlying piece of journalism and then
by the end of it you're exhausted of
whatever you've been writing about
podcasting about making a video on and
so you just like throw on a headline
right and so if the headline is bad it
often doesn't matter if the underlying
piece is good so for this book I think
we had I think I tried to get us to 30
possible headlines and this came in they
this came in later and then it I I don't
think I expected that this one would
stick but it really was what the book
was about and the other which you have
not mentioned but is my true greatest
accomplishment on the book is there was
no subtitle there was no sub time I was
gonna mention that that's very very
impressive
I mean people should buy this book
people should buy this book if for no
other reason than to push the publishing
industry away from subtitles it's
radical I just had a new book proposal
in without a subtitle my agent was like
well what's the subtype I love that you
don't even call it a title you call it a
headline headline you might be new at
writing books but at headline I'm very
new at writing books I just listen I'm a
babe in the woods here but did you enjoy
it I know I'm not counting on the
substance yet but we will get there did
you have fun no this is actually the
conversation I want to have I'm
exhausted the book substance yeah I did
I enjoy it so I signed on to do a book
with Simon & Schuster six ish years ago
and I sold The Washington Post
and then it was a very different book
that I had sold them and it was much
more about the policy-making process and
and institutions and forces in political
life and politics that ended up shaping
policy even though they didn't get a lot
of attention so
exactly Gresh little budget office a
filibuster polarization was in there but
um that it was not the primary thing I
mean I put that down because myself and
Melissa Bella Notte iglesias decided to
start Vox and so I put that book down
and didn't think about it for years and
then about two years ago when I stepped
down as editor-in-chief of Vox one thing
that I had felt when I was
editor-in-chief was that I did not I
wasn't able to do the reporting that
I've been doing in the years prior and
so in some ways I was running off the
fumes of an old understanding of
politics and I was looking around and we
were well into the Trump era now and
just realizing that I didn't have a
model that really explained how we got
from Obama to Trump why things looked
and felt the way they did why politics
was working the way it was my background
is in policy reporting and so I have a
lot of models for what happens when
Congress starts working on a bill and
why it always collapses into total
Humpty shambles but I didn't have a
model about why politics it seemingly
gone off the rails in the way it had and
so this book was an opportunity for me
to try to rebuild my understanding of
politics from the ground up in a way
that created that could help explain
what was happening for me and then and
then hopefully for an audience and so in
that way it was an incredibly difficult
and incredibly rewarding intellectual
process and a humbling one you realize
often times and you've done this more
than I have on much harder topics and
I'm taking on but you realize that there
are things that are operating in your
implicit model of the world that when
you force them down onto the page it
turns out that they're thin yeah or
possibly not even there I'm one of the
big examples of this to me was ever a
chapter it's a penultimate chapter in
the book but it's one of the ones I'm
really proud of on asymmetric
polarization this idea that the right
has gone further right and we should
talk about what that means and the left
has gone left actually don't think left
and right under quite right words there
but the right has become a more it has
responded to polarization by straying
further from the norms of American
politics in the left house across a
variety of different dimensions and this
is a well-known thing in political
science I'm norm Ornstein and Tom an
have written a book about it that's
quite well no one called it's even worse
than it looks
Jacob hacker and Paul Pearson have
written on this so of others what was
striking to me when I began really
looking at that literature because I
believed and could like look around you
can see a symmetric polarization playing
out all around us I thought that there
was a good causal story and there just
wasn't that there are stories about
Mitch McConnell and people doing things
but why those people were the ones who
were being rewarded why they were
emerging on the right and not the left
why had Republicans forced out two
speakers in a couple of years whereas
Democrats in the house are still how led
by the exact same leadership team they
had in O six there was something
different happening in the parties and
while there had been narrative is a
shion's of it there actually was not a
good causal story for it and so having
to actually force unto the page the
model do be reporting to fill in the
gaps and then realize where the stories
that I had been told or that I had seen
had holes that I needed to fill it was
really quite helpful i I mean as you say
in the book the in some ways the
election of Trump was a unique event but
in so many other ways it was just
business as usual in some sense so these
underlying structural questions are
really fascinating like a future
historian would not look at the numbers
of who voted for whom and why and say
that this was anything out of the
ordinary absolutely and and this is
something I'm really trying to do in the
book is to show that what is striking
about Trump is not how different and
aberrant the 2016 election was but in
fact how normal it was how much you just
simply put back together the MIT Romney
coalition with a couple of tweaks on the
sidelines and I do this I show you know
through exit polls going back a couple
of elections hey you really wouldn't be
able to pick this one out of a lineup
but the thing that this hits to a big
story in American life which is that the
two parties have polarized and let me
say let me try to say this very clearly
because polarization is a word that I
think has been thrown around very
incoherently because it can mean a lot
of different things but what has
happened has is the two parties have
sorted themselves by ideology race
religiosity geography culture and
psychology over the past 50 or 60 years
such at what what Republican and
Democrat means how much information
those labels encode is much
larger and it was so-so Vikings what is
her magnetic polarization right because
exactly well I think a lot of people
would just sort of casually conflate it
with disagreement which has been around
for a long time but this is a very
different phenomenon that that's I want
to note a very important point you just
made there because something that is
misleading in when you look back in
American history is people will
sometimes tell a story about
disagreement as a way of disproving the
idea of polarization they will say look
I'm Aaron Burr shot Alexander Hamilton
later made a musical about it as if it's
a well-known fact in American life but
you can go even back to the 60s which
importantly are a nadir of polarization
in in America it's one of the periods in
which our political system is at least
polarized but look around you have
political assassinations you have
student protesters being killed in the
streets you the civil rights movement
the feminism movement the indigenous
rights movement we are at a moat the
anti-war movement we are at a moment
there where the ferocity of disagreement
is such a you have actual violence in
the streets urban riots and so on and
yet the political system itself is not
that polarized so there's a there's a
tendency to look back and say we've all
we've had Republican and Democratic
parties going back to the Civil War
we've had disagreement that at other
times as violent um much more so than it
is now
so come on this can't make it that bad
and in many ways by the way that's very
true this is not comparatively that bad
what is different is that the
disagreements are so well sorted by
party and that is having very distinct
effects both on the nature or how our
disagreements play out what the
political system is able to do in their
midst and and where things are going I
we can talk about this more later but I
think a very very scary thought
experiment is to imagine the level of
genuine Civic division of the 60s and
pasted it on to the political structure
of the what now and now the 2020s and if
you run that you run that one out for a
little bit and you don't end up in a
happy place here at mindscape we often
talk about the future and it can be very
difficult to predict that includes your
personal future that's why insurance was
invented so you can have a little bit of
a cushion when bad things happen and
policy genius can help you figure out
what the right insurance is policy
genius is a way that you can come
hair different life insurance plans from
many different providers in minutes you
compare quotes from the top insurers and
get the best price you could save up to
$1500 or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies for example and once you apply
the policy genius team handles all the
paperwork all the red tape they don't
just make life insurance easy policy
genius helps you find the right home or
auto insurance disability insurance
whatever it is so if you're worried
about predicting the future and getting
it exactly right don't get discouraged
to get life insurance it just takes a
few minutes to find your best price and
apply at policy genius.com policy genius
helps make it easy to move toward the
future you know to me I know this is
just kind of predictable but it sounds
like a physics problem to me I mean you
have a bunch of well when you're
physicist I guess Edison's right and you
know but is it a classical or quantum
physics problem because it's just purely
classical so you don't need quantum
mechanics there's no reaction at a
distance or anything like that but I
think that the physics of politics or
political science is is fascinating to
me and basically you have a collective
phenomenon with many little constituents
and you might say well entropy increases
and that'll stall mix together but in
fact they're sorting as you say in the
book as you make the case very strongly
so the different characteristics of
these of of constituents begin to become
correlated in interesting ways so
clearly they're not just random
particles moving they're interacting
they're being influenced by things by
external forces and figuring out what
those forces are is very important yeah
so something that you see in the book is
that what I'm trying to do is offer a
description and a framework of how a
system is working and something that I
do explicitly and repeatedly is make the
argument that individuals have much
narrower ranges of action than we like
to think it as you say it is it's very
much a classical not a quantum system we
very much can predict where people are
going to end up pretty well
and that's important because I think
that one way in which my own industry
political journalism I don't want to say
misleads people but it ends up confusing
the situation is that we narrative eyes
the story of American politics through
the stories of individual politicians
most salient Lee the president but very
the part of the intellection ears of the
opposing candidate or candidates to some
degree the leaders of the House and
Senate and then there's always a couple
of other players operating with less
formal formally huge bases of power but
an Alexandria Ocasio Cortez it had crews
right these people become political
superstars and as we tell these stories
I mean if you read a book of campaign
narration like Game Change or one of
these you really see it it's you know
there was this meeting at the White
House and the persons that the thing and
the other person walked out and then
they told us and and so everything has
in the way of human interactions this
feeling of indeterminacy well what if
they just said the other thing what if
they just had it made that messaging
mistake what if they what if they just
elected the other person and the
argument I'm making in this is that this
system is driving outcomes and shaping
incentives such that well obviously
there's some range of free will
operating within American politics at
least depending on your broader
metaphysical view of humanity there's
some range of what we think of as free
will operating in American politics it's
pretty narrow and people are much more
to the point the incentives and systems
around them and polarization is in some
ways the master story and master
incentive system of them all are shaping
the way they understand the information
that helps them make decisions shaping
who they trust who they listen to who
they fear who they're trying to attract
and so you can really predict pretty
well what people are gonna do even when
you have tremendously large variation in
the individuals at play and this is why
the story of Trump's presidency is very
telling what we basically did was we ran
it was not a simulation where
unfortunately living through it but we
ran a version of American politics where
we tested the theory we gave the
Republican Party an incredibly app or an
individual a Burin in his ideology
aberrant in his relationship with
Republican Party his relationship to
Republican party elites
abran in how he acted personally the
kinds of things he said the way he
communicated the way he attacked say
what you will about Donald Trump people
who love him will say he's a very
unusual figure people who hate him will
say he's a very unusual figure and you
put this very unusual figure in and what
happens you reconstruct most admit
romney's coalition and then the
republican party falls in line behind
the party leader and he ends up more or
less
as a traditional Republican with a very
unusual Twitter account so if that is
not a test of how much polarization and
the broader political system incentives
contain even the most disruptive figure
I I don't know what is ya know I think
it's an excellent thing and I think that
as a scientist the looking for the
underlying systemic things going on is
is much more educational I don't know if
it's much more important or significant
but it's certainly much more
illuminating to me than telling a story
of Lyndon Johnson in the back room
twisting someone's arm
even though well let me let me ask this
of you because you've read it and you're
did you did the book feel did did the
system feel convincing to you does the
the analysis of the book did the pieces
fit together in a way that you looked at
it and thought yeah like that explains
what I'm seeing or does it feel like the
the pieces don't quite fit yeah it's
always hard to tell I mean Bates roughly
speaking the answer is yes I think it is
a pretty convincing story overall
there's it's this quasi historical
analysis right because the United States
has a history that is very unique with
the civil war and slavery and
reconstruction in the south and the
whole bit I do worry if I'm being really
really rigorous that we can tell
ourselves a story that gives us a warm
and fuzzy feeling about things without
really knowing how to test it rigorously
but to the up to the difficult did you
find this one very warm and fuzzy though
well okay we're buzzy in the sense of
who I understand what's going on not
that I like it but but but let's let's
share with the audience who has not read
the book so we said what polar I mean
actually sorry maybe this went by too
quickly or was embedded into many things
the thing about polarization is that
everyone has characteristics where they
live how old they are religious beliefs
political beliefs economic beliefs but
in principle those could be
independently distributed right you
could have you know economic right-wing
people with socially left-wing people
etc and the polarization is this kind of
sorting where different attitudes become
aligned in a very significant way is
that a fair short summary yeah let me
even back it up one one one more step a
problem of polarization is people do not
tend to say the next word in the
sentence or the description polarization
of what and so if you begin to
into the and in this book as you
mentioned it has some amount of
historical work in it but it's very
heavily inflected by political science
and to some degree social psychology and
then political reporting which is my my
bread and butter but so when you study
polarization there are a couple things
you could be describing and they don't
have to be happening at the same time
and in fact some it can be getting worse
and some getting better but you can have
polarization of policy so the two
parties are have clustered around almost
perfectly opposite policies right one
wants to tax people more the other wants
to end taxes entirely I use the example
I think at some point in the book of
cannabis policy right you could have a
party where one party is for full
legalization of marijuana and give their
party's for full criminalization of it
that would be perfectly polarized on the
policy um then you could have a
situation where you're polarized by what
they call effective a a Fe AFF ECT iv-e
polarization affective polarization what
they mean by that is it's polarization
and how you feel about your party and
the other parties so even if your
policies are not that divergent you're
seeing an increase in how much people
hate the other party one thing worth
noting is we're seeing a lot more
affective polarization than policy
polarization the to interact in
important ways but one thing what has
really really risen up is how negatively
people feel about the other party more
than how much they necessarily to screw
the other party so I want to note that
um then there's a question of are you
looking at elite or Matt or mass
polarization there's a difference
between the country is changing either
and how it feels about the other side or
its own side or what it thinks about
policy and it's just elites doing it and
there's a lot of disagreement about this
but I I think it's a little bit of a
disagreement that a difference but the
the evidence is extremely strong on
elite polarization and that seems to
then be sorting the structure that the
rest of the country has to respond to so
the elites artists are leading the
polarization leads seem to be leading
the leading the charge so one of the
arguments that is central to the book is
that the most important form of
polarization and one of the most
important questions in American politics
just in general is identity polarization
identity politics is a term people have
heard a lot people use it a lot right
now but I am trying to offer what I
think it was a much more rigorous
definition of
and so identity politics in the way we
typically use it in American politics
refers to traditionally marginalized or
weaker groups who are making a claim for
something of importance to their group
African Americans making a claim about
police brutality or Jewish people making
a claim about anti-semitism these would
be traditionally be understood as
identity politics whereas like you know
rural gun owners who want the Second
Amendment expansively interpreted that's
just politics or CEOs who want their
taxes cut as just politics um
but identity is incredibly powerful way
that people operate in the world
I am Californian and the father and I'm
Jewish and I'm a vegan and so on and so
forth and one of the things that is
happening is that our identities are
stacking and connecting to our political
identities and this is what you were
talking about in the setup to this
question which is what we used to have
were very cross-cutting identities that
played across parties so if you go back
to say the 50s and you look at a range
of demographic characteristics there
wasn't more than 10 percentage point
difference in how prevalent those groups
were in either party even aetiology was
not well structured between the parties
you had a lot of liberal Republicans you
had a lot of conservative Democrats you
know when Strom Thurmond was a
Democratic member of the Senate he was
the second most conservative senator
according to two different rankings we
had at that time so a lot of this was
happening as you alluded to because of
race the Dixiecrat which was the
Dixiecrats which were the southern wing
of the Democratic Party
they were quite conservative but
importantly very racially conservative
they functionally ran the south as a
authoritarian system built on protecting
racial hierarchy system but they were
very powerful in the Democratic Party
and so what they created was an almost
blockade around the two parties
coalescing around ideologies they're
part of why you had a lot of liberal
Republicans because um libera libera
popkins who did not agree with what was
happening in the Democratic Party on
race as the civil rights act and and
other things that happened begin to end
that blockage and so you have
conservatives move into the Republican
Party including in the south which is
now the most conservative region of the
country you have liberals move into the
Democratic Party and that for
reasons kicks off this period of sorting
and so now you have back if you go into
the early 20th century the density of a
place does not predict it's partisan
politics but now there's no there is no
cap place in America more dense than
nine hundred people per square mile if
I'm remembering this outright that is
Republican so if you get denser you will
always see a Democrat like all major
cities in America our Democratic
religiosity has become very different so
the Republic parties are overwhelmingly
Christian it used to be that they are
both this way now the single largest
religious group in the Democratic Party
is people who are religiously
unaffiliated in the Democratic parties a
coalition of a lot of different
religious groups liberal Christians
Buddhists you know atheists etc on race
the Democratic Party is I believe it is
forty four percent non-white at least in
its 2016 primary vote the or in its
twenty sixteen vote the Republican party
is over ninety percent white so and I
can keep going like this psychologically
we've sorted you know this is whole
openness to experience stuff for
different ways people play this out but
we had a great conversation with
Wilkinson on the podcast about yes the
urban-rural divide but also the
personality factors and how they come in
and I want to get back to that but keep
going yeah so anyway the point is that
on almost everything you can think of
the parties have over the past fifty
years
sorted so that the identities are
stacking on top of each other
as opposed to crossing so you don't like
you don't have a ton of Union members
who are Republicans you don't have a ton
of rural southerners who are Democrats
and so as that happens and there's a lot
of evidence on this from outside
politics to when you begin to stack
identities the nature of disagreement
becomes much deeper it becomes much more
threatening and more effective
polarization hatred and fear of the
other side loyalty or identification
with your own side is a quite rational
response if if polarization is not as
high in the 60s in part that's because
well if you were a kind of moderate
Democrat looking at the Republican Party
you saw a lot of people like yourself in
it and I'm Richard Nixon domestically at
least did a lot of quite moderate and
even now looking back liberal things and
conversely Bill Clinton did some quite
conservative things and now you look at
the other side and they're much more
different from you demographically
they're much more different than you
ideological II and so the threat they
posed to
and to your view of the good life is
much more severe and so that that's it
the the kind of central form of
polarization now this this stacked
identity polarization that is feeding
into the majoritarian political
identities not just marginalized groups
yes I think that the evidence it's
pretty I always worry when we compare
our era to previous eras because we are
at different ages when we live in
different eras right and so we always
tend to see things to different kinds of
glasses but it seems that there's
quantitative evidence that the
polarization really has increased you've
mentioned a lot of it already but one
thing that I found fascinating that
really drove at home was the undecided
voters disappearing why don't you say
something about that so we just used to
have a lot of let me put that I actually
think that the simplest way to put this
is looking at ticket splitting and I
don't have all these numbers right in
front of me right now but basically
ticket splitting was very very very
common 30 or 40 years ago so you might
vote for a Democrat for president and
then a Republican for your member of
Congress the south was full of ticket
splitting predating the post-civil
rights act era so they began voting they
begin voting routinely for Republicans
for president not every state in the
south but but it happens a lot but there
there's nevertheless until that
generation dies out the south had an
enmity towards the Republican Party due
to the Republican Party invading and
occupying it during the Civil War
so the affiliation is to Democrats and
to the southern Dixiecrats
and so they continue to actually have a
hammerlock on the south for quite some
time even as at the national level the
south begins to trend towards the
Republican Party so there was a lot of
ticket splitting I think the numbers I
have in the book are that the
correlation in your vote between House
and presidential in terms of partisan
lean is something like during these
periods 0.5 in 2018 I believe it was
0.98 so the correlation goes from being
real but not necessarily everything to
basically everything yeah undecided
voters true undecided voters and it's
worth saying an interesting facet of all
this is that this high rise in
polarization is happening at a time when
we have more and more independent
self-styled independents but it turns
out that most independents are just
partisans in disguise
for I have a lot of evidence on this in
the book but independent is a good
personal brand if you give people
pictures of folks and you ask them to
rate how attractive they are but you
also say if they're Republicans
Democrats or independents people will
rate objectively less attractive people
more attractive if they're told their
independence independent is a great
political brand I think we made the
number of people more romantic advice
here in the mindscape podcast so I like
that so for your personal ads audience
independence is Republic my job is
politics
my passion is offering people
relationship advice so anytime I wanted
to do that I'm here for it if you own a
business or manage a business you know
that hiring people is probably the most
important most crucial task that you
have and it can be very very difficult
but it doesn't have to be so difficult
with LinkedIn jobs LinkedIn jobs a
website of course but it screens
candidates with both the hard skills and
soft skills that you personally are
looking for so you can hire the right
person fast things like collaboration
creativity adaptability LinkedIn looks
beyond the work skills and puts your job
post in front of qualified candidates
who match your business requirements
perfectly it's no wonder a person is
hired every eight seconds with LinkedIn
jobs and that's why companies rate
LinkedIn jobs the number one hiring
platform for delivering quality hires so
find the right person for your business
today with LinkedIn jobs you can pay
what you want and get the first 50
dollars off by visiting linkedin.com
slash mindscape again that's LinkedIn
comm slash mindscape to get $50 off your
first job post terms and conditions
apply you used to have a pretty fair
number of what they called floating
voters voters who won election to
another would change who they're voting
for and a stat I love and this comes
from the political scientist Alan
Abramovich's
and again I should have have a book in
front of me right now but I don't butt
in I think it is the 70s the swing in
how a state votes at the presidential
level from election to election is I
believe it is 8 or 9 percentage points
so if you know how the state voted for
president one year in the next election
you can expect a pretty
magnificent swing and where they're
going now it's under two percentage
points so states have become much more
fixed in political place um there's no
question about is California going to
vote for the Democrat when 80/20 just
there's no question about whether or not
West Virginia vote for the Republican so
across basically every form of data we
can look at people are becoming much
more stable in their political
preferences and it's something that I
cannot emphasize enough is this makes
sense this is a rational response to
what has happened which is it the two
parties to become much more different
another piece of evidence I love this
comes from Corwin Schmidt who's a
political scientist is that today people
who are self felt independent voters or
low information voters they are as
certain and when polled about the
differences between the two parties are
the two candidates as people who are
strong partisans or high information
voters were in the 70s so if you told a
pollster in the 70s you're like yes I am
a die-hard Democrat and they said to you
well how sure like how confident are you
that you can name the differences
between you know how Richard Nixon and I
don't know McGovern would govern you'd
say you know at this point um being
timid who doesn't really like politics
or a feel that other parties you are
stronger on that question that's not
because the people back then were lying
it's because now the differences are
much much much bigger and so rationally
it is easier to be I make the the way I
put in the book is it it is harder to
tell a donkey apart from a mule then to
tell a donkey apart from an elephant
mm-hmm absolutely and I think that
there's also a positive feedback loop
which is a point you make in the book
because it used to be that 20% of the
voters were really persuadable show I
vote for the Republican and the Democrat
and now I think it the number was like
less than 7% which means that if you
want to win an election don't spend all
your time trying to convince those
people trying to try to spend the time
have your rabid partisans get out the
vote actually show up and therefore you
go you preach to your converted yeah so
the second half of the book is about the
feedback loops had been set off in
American politics by polarization and I
talk particularly about the media about
how elections are run about the
presidency and about the
about governance and in the presidency
in Congress and then about the two
political parties as institutions and
what you're saying there is a hundred
percent true so it used to be the way
you're trying to do in elections was by
for these persuadable people in the
middle and these are usually people with
a lot of cross-cutting identities
reasonably weak policy opinions and you
know what they wanted was somebody who
they could see themselves in and so you
have the two political parties running
candidates pretty often who fuzz the
difference in men think of Bill Clinton
as a New Democrat who you know he he
makes a big show of the ways in which
he's conservative his identities are
southern he's a white man he says he's
gonna end well far as we know it he's a
Democrat but he said Democrat a
conservative might look at and think or
certainly an independent might look at
and think you know I can kind of get
behind that guy george w bush runs is a
compassionate conservative he makes a
point of saying he's gonna you know
really focus on the racial education gap
and he makes a point of you know saying
that we shouldn't balance our budgets on
the backs of the poor and so there's a
very long period in american politics
when the strategy used to win an
election is to try to choose a candidate
and then choose a set of issues there
are going to be good for a voter who is
persuadable to you but doesn't quite
agree and that naturally pulls you
towards the middle now as the number of
persuadable voters has gone down what
you have our candidates who are running
base mobilization strategies Donald
Trump secure base mobilization candidate
Barack Obama rhetorically you know would
make his feints towards the middle but
as a symbolic candidate an
african-american who from from an urban
area who is a constitutional law
professor at the U of Chicago he's very
much a candidate for democratic
mobilization and it looks like where
Democrats may go we'll see you know
could certainly it looks like the
Democratic Party is moving in a base
mobilization direction as Republicans
have the big inflection point here seems
to be the 2004 election under george w
bush but what's very important about
this is that it it's it's not a one-way
system so as the candidacies as a
political parties begun run begin
running more base mobilization
strategies what they do is a further
polarize the electorate so if you are
dealing with
waste between say Bernie Sanders and
Donald Trump it's much easier for you as
a member of the electorate to decide
which side of that you're on then when
you were looking at a choice between
George HW Bush and Bill Clinton but as
you did the Democratic Party moves left
and moves sort of in a democratic
socialist direction and moves very quite
a bit to the left on immigration and
race which are very powerful political
issues and the Republican Party moves
right on them that polarizes the public
- people follow their parties they take
cues they develop their opinions from
their parties and then when people look
around there's this huge gap between
them and so in deciding between the two
of them you sort of move in one
direction or another it's harder to be
locked in that in that kind of mushy
middle and if you're gonna give if
you're gonna boil down the explanation
to a sentence so you know why we why
we're polarized is is it the Dixiecrat
explanation is that the single most
important thing I mean that it's a
compelling historical story but that it
seems unique to the United States it
seems like something that would not
explain things elsewhere but maybe I
should be asking as a question are other
countries polarized and other countries
are very highly polarized yeah what the
the Dixiecrat thing is not I would say
the explanation for polarization at all
okay what the Dixiecrat thing is is the
explanation for why is it is the primary
explanation for why did America have a
period of depolarized parties in the
middle of the twentieth century okay so
number one for most of American history
or at least much of it America was quite
polarized if you go back to say before
the Civil War that was a very polarized
country that ended up having political
parties where one wanted to invade part
of the other so we have had polarization
here before and we have it very sharply
in other countries I mean look at the UK
there's a very big difference between
the Labour Party of Jeremy Corbyn and
Tory Party of Boris Johnson I recognise
Johnson has moderated a bit on things
like the National Health Service but
there's still quite a bit of
polarization there in general political
parties tend towards polarization for
all kinds of obvious reasons if you are
trying to be a product on a political
market so to speak you need to
differentiate from the other products
race is a reason and basically in the
20th century America was a four party
system it was Democrats dixiecrats
liberal Republicans and conservative
Republicans and then it
laughs down into a two-party system and
as the Dixiecrat ik blockage undid
itself but that is not why we're
polarized it's actually the incentives
of political systems of and I would also
say at this point
social media systems and others I mean
we can talk about other other other
things in the polarization stack but I I
think it's a very very important point
to say that mid twentieth century
America is both for us and his end
globally that is the aberration yeah
okay no you have a high part like high
salience political high information high
salience political systems with multiple
political parties polarization is
usually the result what is distinct
about America and we can talk about this
is that most political systems function
just fine amid polarization whoever has
a majority is able to govern America's
political system which was designed to
resist political parties is distinct in
that it does not function well in its
polarization you need pretty high levels
of consensus in the American political
system to do anything at all and so one
particular threat polarization place to
us compared to poses to us compared to
other countries is basically making a
ambitious governance in this country
impossible over the long term yeah that
is gonna be a problem but I like this
that way of putting it that became clear
even though I read your book when you
just said it that the Dixiecrat
phenomenon is more about explaining why
we weren't polarized and maybe arguably
polarization is a more natural thing but
okay if that's the case let me bring up
the the counter expectation may be like
if polarization is a way of
characterizing the fact that along
multiple different dimensions people's
beliefs or preferences are are
correlated why why should they be why
should my you know religion or race be
correlated with my feelings about the
estate tax do you think that really is a
natural thing or is this again something
because we're in a society that sort of
sorts us by identity in different ways I
don't think it is a logical thing but I
think it is a natural thing and it is in
this way we have a often quite naive
view of how people form their politics
which is to say there is this classical
view that what people are doing is
they're you know getting up blinking
their eyes like wiping the sleep out of
them and looking
saying how do I feel about the estate
tax about about capital gains tax rates
do I think China is a currency
manipulator is it a good idea to
assassinate Soleimani will that do more
to stabilize or destabilize the Middle
East um should we have a single-payer
health care system or would it be better
to have a multi payer system or just the
universal catastrophic as soon as you
begin running through the number of
decisions that American politics asks us
in theory to make or maybe the clear way
to put that is the number of questions
American politics asks us to have
preferences on it becomes quickly
ridiculous should we have a carbon tax
or should we just fund R&D into new
energy research you know nobody
including people who do this
professionally can have an informed
opinion and a truly informed opinion on
that many things political parties are
these crucial mediators of American
politics and so what functionally
happens the way most people opera
operationalize their politics is they
attach to a party whether or not they
admit they're doing this or not to say
we're to the independence and then they
let that they trust that party more or
less to either make decisions for them
or and this is very important to
sometimes they don't really trust a
party they vote for but they really
really fear the other part right there
are a lot of people who are Republicans
not loving Donald Trump but they hate
the Democrats a lot of Democrats who
don't love the Democrats but they they
really do not wanna see Donald Trump
reelected and so then the question is
why do we attach to political parties in
this way and that's where identity
becomes really important and so what
you're basically seeing the the way that
the way the causal chain actually goes
is that the political parties are
connected to certain identities for a
bunch of different reasons you brought
up the example of race here the party's
traditional cleavages on race going to
the kind of post-civil rights act era
where in the subsequent election Barry
Goldwater runs against the Civil Rights
Act I'm sorry not the subsequent
election of the election Barry Goldberg
runs against civil rights act and then
Lyndon Johnson is for it
that is a key moment in American
politics so what is happening there and
I want to note this for a minute because
it's show
you had different the depolarized and
the the the polarized periods are
Republicans supported the Civil Rights
Act in Congress in very large numbers so
actually as a proportion of members of
Congress of their own party Republicans
voted for the Civil Rights Act both in
the House and Senate at a higher
proportion then Democrats did but then
in the election Barry Goldwater runs
against a civil rights act and Lyndon
Johnson is for it and so as opposed to
this being a bipartisan accomplishment
it quickly becomes a cleavage between
the parties when it could have been the
reverse you very much could imagine a
Republican Party that had become the
party of civil rights as it had been
traditionally was Abraham Lincoln's
party and the Democratic Party with the
Dixiecrats who went the other way but
this does begin to kick off this period
where the republican party's a home for
the the white identity politics backlash
to the civil rights movement and so the
Democratic Party becomes a party of
non-white Americans a party that has a
investment in and a policy agenda built
for a more diverse in diversifying
country and so people who are not white
tend to grow up in house is it a
democratic and they are attached to
Democratic Party through that identity a
lot of people who are white or having
the opposite experience predicting the
South with the Republican Party and then
having done that they take their views
on the estate tax from the party or more
often than not they don't think about
the estate tax at all because it's very
rarely a central issue in American
politics so identity attaches you to
party and then party helps filter for
you what you believe in who you believe
about what will be better for the
country but the idea that what is
happening is that people are maybe
listeners a mindscape bar but most
people do not sit down look at the 50
policy items they think are gonna come
before Congress this year and recent
backwards from them they reason forward
from who they already trust yeah I think
that nobody does I don't think that Ed
Witten or Stephen Hawking does that you
know we where we have these finite
cognitive capacities right you know if
you read Thinking Fast and Slow we
reasoned by heuristics and the
psychology of it is fascinating to me
and you tell the story in the book which
is I'd heard it before but I can never
hear it enough times about how politics
makes you stupider even when it just
comes to doing math problems why don't
you share that one with the audience
yeah so and and I would twist out in one
way which is
more than that it's it makes smart
people very stupid right it's a smarter
you [ __ ]
so the bath problem story is there are a
group of researchers led by Dan kahan at
Yale Law School
who've done this great work on political
psychology and-and-and partisan
motivated reasoning or as he puts it
which I like even better
we calls identity protective cognition
mmm-hmm so there are times when we're
just reasoning to the truth but times
when what we're doing is reasoning to
protect our identity and our standing in
the group and so one of the experiments
they did which is very clever was they
gave people this basically a brain
teaser it's a math problem built so that
if you look at it quickly you're gonna
get it wrong and in one version of the
math problem it's about how well a
skincare cream worked and when you give
people that math problem you get exactly
what you would expect which is people
who are better at math Sean Carol get
the mouth problem right my dad this
mathematician I'm sure would get the
math problem right and people who are
not as good at math get it wrong but
then they had a variant in the study
which is they gave you the exact same
problem same proportions same tendency
towards fooling people but now it's
about how well a gun control policy
worked from one party of the other and
all of a sudden when you do that
particularly for people who are better
at math math stops being helpful in
giving you the right answer what whether
or not you get the right answer is
whether or not you believe in gun
control right and so even people the I
love this finding Gravette the disparity
is biggest among the people who are best
at math yeah and this ladder is out and
I have a lot of evidence around this in
the book but a lot of thought to all
kinds of different things this smarter
you are and even a more drug way of
putting it the more high information you
are as a voter what it tends to do is
give you a lot of cognitive resources to
convince yourself of why what your group
believes or what you want to believe is
already correct whatever that thing is
whatever that is if you've ever tried to
argue with a climate change denier
something you will find is that they are
often quite informed about some aspects
of science it is a terrific performance
of scientific inquiry and by the way
they would listen to me right now and
say you know the climate change
believers are doing this performance of
scientific inquiry
but if you if you or if you've talked to
somebody's in 9/11 truther they know a
lot about melting points of steel right
the issue is not he the issue here is
not that people have the wrong views
because they're dumb oftentimes the
reason they have very wrong views is
because they're quite smart and that has
given them an incentive to go out and
search for the wrong views or answers or
information that will back them up in
the wrong views there's some good work
from Larry Bartels and Christopher
Aikens in the book they've this
wonderful paper that's called it feels
like we're thinking and and the point of
it is that when they ask people did the
budget deficit get bigger or smaller
under Bill Clinton there's actually
answer to that question but the more
informed Republicans are likelier to
answer it wrong than less informed
Republicans and going backwards more
partisan Democrats or less likely know
that inflation had fallen under Ronald
Reagan and that's because if you have
ever read the National Review or you
know the New Republic or whatever it
might be if you are going around in the
Bill Clinton era and you're like a not
very informed Republican you probably
know you don't like Bill Clinton but you
don't know that much about the economy
and you probably heard the deficit came
down and so fine like I don't like book
Clinton deficit has come down if you're
a reader of the National Review in that
period you're hearing a lot about the
size of the trade deficit with China and
there's a credit bubble and so on and
there's a lot of ways to arrange the
facts that you think oh no the economies
in general getting worse the deficit is
fake you know like there are these huge
unfunded liabilities in Social Security
and so you answer that a different way
so we mediate not just the information
we believe and not just whom we trust
which is crucial but the information
we're actually looking for by what our
what our site is and so the people who
are very smart and very committed in
politics they are better than other
people are at finding the information to
tell them that what they already believe
is right yeah no I think this is I think
in the very first a little solo thing I
did to announce the existence of this
podcast I talked about how I wanted a
common theme to be what we pay attention
to when it comes to deciding what's
right and wrong there's reasoning
capacities which math is standing in for
here but there's also the evidence that
we look for
but if I'm doing my recalling correctly
it was a couple weeks ago but in your
book you you mentioned that the
probability or the fact that if you do
try to listen to alternate viewpoints to
people who you don't believe that can
often backfire I found and push you away
from it I think what was called the
backfire effect maybe wasn't
reproducible but there is this sort of
defensiveness that we get when we hear
opinions different than ours that can
cause us to retrench yeah and what I
would say is that that is not and one
reason it's a hard thing to reproduce in
some there are two things here the
backfire effect which is I think what
you're talking about is actually a
little bit different the backfire effect
the way political scientists use it is
the idea that even when something that
is wrong is disproven that can make you
believe it more strongly yeah right so
if I say to you that's why I paused when
I said backfire because that's the word
right
but if Barack Obama here is something
like if you believe the birther attack
on Barack Obama and then you read a New
York Times article saying actually no
he's born in Hawaii that that can make
you believe the birther attack all the
more because you like will screw the New
York Times might be true for some people
not as true as the early studies on that
suggested um but what you're saying is
also true but I want to I want to be
careful because it's true in certain
conditions and here's a place where
identity and groups matters a lot so
there's a study I talked about in the
book Chris Bale and other people Duke
did the study which is they paid people
and this was the largest group they ever
did this with or anything like this with
um who are on Twitter they paid them to
let them insert in their Twitter feeds
members of the other political party
right influencers from the other
political party and they had a way of
defining this and it was you know people
who were very heavily followed on the
other side and so they they put them in
the Twitter feeds to see what would
happen and what happened was that it
made Republicans more conservative to
see a bunch of liberals in their Twitter
feed and while the effect was not
statistically significant if it did
anything among liberals it was to make
them more liberal and this was by the
way testing where they went on policy
issue so it's interesting that it didn't
have as big effect on liberals we can
talk about I think actually the right
thing to say that was more research as
needed into why but it definitely did
not make liberals less liberal right
that did not happen right and the thing
I would say there is it there is a very
big difference
between reading the other side
quote-unquote when they literally think
the other side talking to their own
people in a way that is gonna piss you
off and reading somebody from the other
side whom you trust who you don't even
really see as on the other side and who
is actually trying to convince you so
one of the examples I sometimes use of
this is that if you are a liberal and
you want to see what the other side
thinks in a way that might affect you
somewhat and you start reading Breitbart
that is not gonna work because Breitbart
is there to offend you they're not
actually talking to you they are I'm
talking to their own side their whole
approach to politics is about
exacerbating conflict whereas conversely
if you read Ross Douthat in The New York
Times that is a like a like a
center-right conservative who is tuning
his arguments to a liberal audience he
knows right he he structures it in a way
where he grants some points and then he
and then he makes his point so I don't
think it is impossible to have your mind
changed certainly not even for me and
and let me say that a sec I don't think
it is impossible to have your mind
changed or to construct an informational
ecosystem where exposure to alternative
viewpoints gives you more empathy or
even you find some of those viewpoints
actually persuasive but the way people
often do it which is they try to read
the other side if you if the other side
is not trying to talk to you and it is
structured such that you actually feel
oppositional towards them it won't work
what you need is people who you actually
kind of think of as on your side they
just happen to have some different
political opinions in who - and you're
talking to them so again a very big
difference between you've a really smart
friend who has some different views on
China than you do and you might be
willing to listen to that versus you
turn on Fox News and Laura Ingraham is
ranting about China and you're probably
not gonna listen to that that's a really
excellent point and I don't think I've
ever thought of that quite explicitly
because I was gonna ask you know how can
we be better because I know that I and
you and everyone else has these biases
has these filters has these things we
pay attention to so part of the
prescription would be we need more
people who we disagree with who are
never less trying to talk to us
do such people exist either way like I
know that I'm on Twitter and I really
try to get better and better but still
it's way easier to just be sarcastic
about dumb things the other side does
then to give a positive substantive
pitch to the other side for people that
I think for opinions that I have Twitter
is very bad in general it's not a good
place to do this Twitter is built to
exacerbate conflict and disagreement um
I have a couple things to say here one
is that I want to see this very clearly
these are systems that surround us all
including very much me like there's not
a thing I argue in the Box when I am NOT
at some point guilty of what I'm trying
to in many ways do is understand the
system that shapes what I end up doing
and what choices I have and so this is
not something where people should ever
feel that like somebody has escaped it
and like they're being criticized this
is like every one of us is trapped
inside of it and it's hard to get any
elevation on it I just I want to note
that because it's a it's an important
point for me um
but number two I think there are two
questions there one is can we do things
that will make the system better and the
other though is is one of those things
to try to reduce our own levels of
polarization and one thing that has
happened in the discourse around
polarization is it is coded as a
negative word but it'd be polarized as
bad polarization as bad but as I said
earlier most political systems are quite
polarized
um there's natural reasons you might be
polarized you may want your own thinking
process to be as clear-headed as you can
get it but even doing that you might
still be quite polarized in some ways
you might be more polarized right it's
possible for instance that and I would
say this is true that if you want to
have a very clear-eyed process that is
not overly influenced by American kind
of pressure campaigns and politicians
and and and status quo bias on say
health care you're gonna end up
supporting something dramatically to the
left of what America has doesn't need to
necessarily be a Canada cell
single-payer you may want German style
multi-payer but nevertheless you're not
going to be like within the boundaries
of the middle of the the American debate
what we are puff care system is
ridiculous and terrible on every level
so I don't think that this one
surely depolarize you and I don't
necessarily think it needs to the thing
that I do tell people to do more than I
tell them to try to if you want to find
people who you'll listen to from the
other side I think that's great and
everybody should do it and I can give
you my recommendations for people on
both sides of that but I think the thing
people should do that is the most useful
not just for the system but for them
personally is to engage less with the
national politics and more with state
and local politics that we have over the
past you know a couple decades for a
bunch of reasons some of them
technological some of them in terms of
the overall media financial system and
and and business models some of them
just having to do with what has happened
to American politics people have in
general made a huge turn towards
nationalizing their political
information and nationalizing their
political identities and I have a lot of
evidence about this in the book it is
rather than being on Twitter like
shooting off tweets about how Donald
Trump is bad into the ether like
actually join some group near you that
does real political work like actual
like activism or interest group or you
know helping people fill out their taxes
in your community whatever it might be
and move some of your political news
consumption over to state and local
sources just because those are important
identities it's much more nourishing to
be involved locally and like a very
powerful form it's something that is
very good at restraining polarization is
is local is local political identity for
a very long time one of the ways that
the parties kept pulsation reasonably
low or lower in America is it yeah it
may be true that you're a Republican but
you're a Republican from this one
district in Oklahoma in Oklahoma and if
you voted for that bill they would help
you rebuild the bridge in that one
district in Oklahoma and so yeah that
was a democratic bill but you're in your
Republican but you're from Oklahoma and
what matters is that your people have a
bridge and like this is how politics
worked for a long time and then under
john bainer they got rid of earmarks and
you know i would say getting rid of the
earmarks is more of a symptom than a
cause of nationalization but it was also
an accelerant of nationalization and so
the more people reinvest in state and
local political identities I think the
healthier politics will tend to be
but also just they'll be able to change
things people might listen to you you've
more ability to affect them it's more
important in many ways I push people not
to just think about how to modulate
their national political identities but
how to reinvigorate their their more
local ones but the thing about the
earmarks is is interesting because I was
gonna ask about just the game theory of
it if you are a politician you know I
had this amateurish theory that over
time politicians have just become better
at working in their personal
self-interest which is mostly getting
reelected and if the process that we
have to get elected is first you get
nominated by your party and then you run
against the other party and most parts
of the country are predominantly one
party or the other and the primary
election is really the important one
then you're driven to extremism or at
least driven to identify very strongly
with that party's feelings about a whole
suite of issues is that at all
sensible here or is that vicious that's
completely true um you know there's a
great line from the political scientist
Julia's re in the book and her line is
the central fact of this era is that we
live in a period of weak parties and
strong partisanship right so one way of
saying what you're saying is that it's
not just you have to run in your own
party's primary but it used to be that
your own party controlled that primary
in a relatively official way so to use
maybe presidential primaries is the
example here we used to to decide who is
going to be the presidential candidate
through a convention vote right and
there would be I mean there were
examples of these votes needing to be
retaken hundreds of times is the
different groups horse traded and so
Donald Trump could never have been the
Republican Party nominee because he
would have never won delegates at a
convention he could only be the
Republican Party nominee after reforms
made to the primary process so that
primaries were actually the we're
actually quite binding and so that thing
where primaries are not just important
and we haven't just gerrymandered and
and sorted such that people tend to run
in elections that are whoever wins the
the party nomination is gonna win from
the relevant party but we've also made
the primaries we like to think of it as
small d-- democratic-- but in fact very
few people vote in say a house
primary very few people vote in Senate
primaries and so in fact and making them
small D democratically made them very
unrepresentative because it is the small
group of activists and party loyalists
who come out and so you have to be very
afraid of them and not that afraid of
anyone else look um if you're in Utah or
South Carolina you're just not gonna
lose at the Senate level to a Democrat
it's not gonna happen and so you know a
couple years ago in Utah Bob Bennett was
beat in a primary by Mike Lee Bob
Bennett was a conservative Republican
but he also is known for working with
Democrats like with Ron Wyden on a
particular health bill called the
healthy Americans Act and that was part
of why he was beaten um and and you see
this kind of playing out in different
places and so yes it is I think your
game theory there is more or less right
but I do want to note that it's not just
primaries necessarily but it's also the
weakness of parties right and it has
also a relationship to this small D
democratization in the sense of the
question how direct is our democracy
versus how mediated is it through we
vote for people and let them make
decisions I had the wonderful wonderful
podcast with Edward Watts who is a
historian about the fall of the Roman
Republic and the rubberman public foul
and became an empire but it lasted for
500 years and it really worked well for
those 500 years in part because it
defined itself in opposition to Greek
democracy which was direct so anytime
you wanted to have a military campaign
the whole citizenry would vote on what
to do and it turned out to be a disaster
but I think that I can clearly see
advantages and disadvantages in handing
more power to the elites right to make
these decisions some decisions they'll
make a little bit more wisely but maybe
they're gonna also have their own
interests in mind is that is this
something where we even have an
intelligent conversation about this
these days it is not something we have
an intelligent conversation but let me
let me take this in two conflicting
directions one is that Larry bartels and
Chris Aikens in their book democracy for
realest which is a book on very much
recommend people read it they make this
argument I think they they have a nice
little name for it that I'm forgetting
now but they basically say that in
America
whenever there is a problem in democracy
our answer is always more democracy like
we we just have a value system such that
you're never allowed to say that the
problem with this small D democratic
process is that it has gone too far and
you should Ratchet it back you always
have to be at least in theory appealing
to a small d-- democratic-- instinct now
that might lead you to say and similarly
what I just said about primary
conventions might lead you to say well
we you know should get rid of that right
we should move back towards elite
gatekeepers and so on and maybe um there
are places where that might be true but
on the other hand I would say that if we
actually were a democracy a small D
democracy Donald Trump wouldn't be
president and Mitch McConnell wouldn't
be the Senate Majority Leader and
Republicans wouldn't have built this
firewall at the Supreme Court and I
think we'd be in better shape part of
what is the problem in our system right
now is that we don't live in a democracy
we live in a very weird political system
that amplifies the power of rural mostly
white and affluent voters and so through
that kind of like distortive lens where
there's just a paper that came out
showing mathematically that because of
the electoral colleges tilt towards
Republican leaning areas that
Republicans should be expected to win
65% of presidential contests where they
closely lose a popular vote that's
pretty concerning I think um so you can
imagine a system where it really was
majority vote rules and in that world I
think the Republican Party would have to
moderate quite a bit if we're gonna
continue being competitive at the
national level which it could do by the
way I'm Charlie Baker and Larry Hogan
are very popular Republican governors of
blue states but right now Republicans
are winning elections despite losing
more votes and so on the one hand I am
sympathetic to claims that you know we
have gone too far in the direction of
breaking down gatekeepers on the other
hand given like I find that I find that
the argument that we are too
undemocratic undemocratic has more
immediacy and more power than the
argument that we are overly small D
Democratic hmm which doesn't quite let
me give me a prescription for making
things better there
to keep in mind when we try to make
things better yeah I mean if one of the
aspects that puzzles me is just that if
there is this polarization you know you
just talked about if the Republicans
just have a slightly lower popular vote
is it surprising that the polarization
sorts us into approximately 50/50 groups
it is very surprising so I have talked
to so couple things on this Francis Lee
wrote up great political scientist in
Maryland called insecure majorities and
what she shows and I have this chart in
the book which everybody should buy when
she shows is that this is the most
competitive era in American politics
ever for most of American political
history we've had what they call sun and
moon parties we have had a modified
one-party system there was a long period
when Republicans held power after the
Civil War long period for Democrats
tended hold power after the after the
Great Depression
um we can sometimes miss this in
retrospect because the presidential
level has been a lot more competitive
than the Congressional level but if you
kind of aggregate all this together what
used to have is long periods of
functional one-party dominance with much
larger majorities and you have here and
so that led me to ask so Lee argues this
is a big reason for polarization and
kind of winner-takes-all politics that
everybody's always so close to either
winning or losing power that it creates
this desperation there's no holds barred
nature to the political tactics and
approaches they'll endorse and so
everything is is in a state of like
constant knife's edge competition
everybody's always playing like it's
overtime and they're you know they're
one point down but it led me to ask her
and others well why wait why are we so
well sorted right now why is it so close
and political scientists do not have an
answer to this question and and I have
my theories specifically I have a theory
that the media plays to some degree and
nationalized political media plays like
like a thermostatic function where
because media is reasonably oppositional
to whoever's in power it tends to cover
scandals and mistakes the media likes
conflict it like to navigate it likes
negativity and because whoever is out of
power is more desperate
and you can nationalize that desperation
much more easily now I suspect that it's
creating a bit of a thermostatic result
but nevertheless it's weird it's
genuinely weird as a weird period in
American politics we don't have a very
good answer for why it's happening and
nobody has a real theory of how it will
change I think that this is why we need
more the physics of politics this is the
book I'm gonna write okay but you also
also mentioned the media this was the
the final thing that really sort of
wanted to home in on to the extent that
things are changing in to the extent
that we want to look for systemic or
structural explanations rather than just
blaming Mitch McConnell or Bill Clinton
or whatever the biggest obvious change
we've had over the past several decades
is in the way people get their
information right that's it seems that
way to me anyway whether it's Twitter or
whether it's just the fact that we read
screens or whether the fact that we
don't all watch Walter Cronkite at night
despite this homeostatic impulse to keep
conflict going is is it clear that
there's a relationship between increased
polarization and the fragmentation of
the media or is that just a correlation
that may or may not be causal I so I the
chopper on the media I think the media's
a huge player here I don't know that I
would say I think it is the main player
or it's like the only thing or the main
thing that's changed in this period but
there's no doubt that the media is a
huge player in polarization and and I
would pull out a couple of things there
the way that media has changed is that
we have entered into an era of choice
based media yeah nationalised choice
based media and so I've great research
in here for Marcus Pryor and I talk with
people like Jonah Peretti from BuzzFeed
and I mean my background is in media and
I'm you know I've started an
organization the whole thing so I've
seen this from a lot of different angles
but it used to be that people bought a
television to watch I Love Lucy and then
they were also there when the news
happened right because the news happened
the same time every night and like all
of them did the news at the same time
every night like that was how that
worked
similar issue with radio you might get a
newspaper because you want to get the
sports section but on the front pages
politics what Marcus Pryor and others
have found is that as we entered into
the era of cable news and
internet news what happened is we sorted
by preference so there was a theory that
with all this information we'd become
much more knowledgeable about politics
and that didn't happen and what had
happened is that the people who were
very invested and interested in politics
became much much much more knowledgeable
whereas the people who didn't like
political news just opted out altogether
and so one of the key things here and
this is Wow - slightly reverse the
causality on what you said is it the
media had to begin competing for a much
more polarized audience okay because
that was the audience that was still
interested so the people who it used to
have because you had a local newspaper
monopoly or there are only three Network
News channels they were gone and by the
way in some ways is more like a early
forms of media in this country
newspapers he should just be partisan
outlets most newspapers in the early
period of the country were funded or
attached in an explicit way to political
parties and that's why you still see
something like the Arizona Republic used
to be called the Arizona Republic in the
Arkansas democrat-gazette
yeah Democrat Gazette is a democratic
paper not anymore but that's how they
were started I'm so you can still see
vestiges of that in the media now but so
the but what happened in 20th century is
that went away we had these monopolistic
business models or government-granted
monopolies business models and what
you're trying to do there was be
inoffensive you needed everybody who
might shop at the department store to
read the newspaper and that meant you
couldn't be swinging too far to one side
or the other as we entered this era of
unbelievable choice and attention based
media and people who did not like
politics could watch the home gardening
Network and people did like politics
could watch cable news it turned out
that the audience for politics for
people who already had very strong
opinions very strong political
identities because otherwise why would
you actually be paying that much
attention and that forced the media to
run more polarized more polarized more
polarizing stories which in turn
polarize is the audience this is another
one of these feedback loops the audience
gets more polarizing Mead he becomes
more polarized to compete and it kind of
keeps going on like that if you compare
the kind of the intensity let's call it
of New York Times or Washington Post
headlines to where they were 15 or 20
years ago it's no there's no comparison
I mean even if very August institutions
still understood as trying to hew to
some version of you know quote unquote
objective journalism they've
changed a lot and so I think the media
is a very big player here but I see the
media like everything else as operating
within a system it isn't so much that
people in the media woke up one day and
they're like we'd like to polarize of
the country it's at the country
polarized their audience polarized and
as they began to write still good true
reasonable stories that ended up with
them developing more polarized audiences
and kind of you know and then you would
have more competition from the rise of a
Fox News or something and like that
creates pressure on the system so
choice-based hyper competitive media is
gonna be a polarizing form of media and
that's what we've seen I mean it seems
to me correct me if I'm wrong here
because you are the expert but that's
even evident to me I think at Vox
it seemed yes absolutely at the
beginning it was trying much harder to
be completely non-judgmental about
things and just the language the
rhetoric is a bit more like come on this
is crazy I actually don't know that I
agree with that it I I think it's true
about box in a big way I'm not sure I
think that's true about our beginning in
some ways I think were I know if I'd say
tone down I think a hard thing in this
is Trump made all this a lot harder yeah
that is it and this isn't this is
another way in which the system's your
the reality you're dealing with is hard
for me to state clearly what is going on
in the White House by the way even what
people in the White House are telling me
is going on in the White House is to say
things that sound like Oh slander right
the president is lying the president is
saying a bunch of incoherent things
about windmills yeah the president made
a bunch of bigoted statements today the
president made fun of somebody's weight
the president tweeted I mean literally
just um just a couple days ago now the
president retweeted some random person
on Twitter who had photoshopped Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi into like
Muslim garb and said they love the
Ayatollah like for me to say clearly
what is going on has just become itself
more polarizing so some of what you're
seeing there is I think in an accurate
rendering a reality that said um I'm
somebody I come from the blogging
background I've worked at The Washington
Post and and so on but I believe in
saying clearly but I think we found of
what I think is true but I
have a lens right I'm a liberal person
and I have certain values and
commitments and Tim I try very hard to
look for the truth but there's no doubt
you know that at some level I believe
immigrants coming in this country are a
good thing not a bad thing and that in
inflex how I cover things where I think
gay marriage is a good thing not a bad
thing so you know Vox like a lot of
places it is not hue to an idea that you
should write story headlines where it is
unclear what the conclusion of the story
is or write stories where it's unclear
what the conclusion of the story is but
Vox started in the age of social media
and so like a lot of groups that are in
the age of social media I think that
made our headlines more overheated hmm
and more polarizing on me and so and so
I think you know like my view is you
know we do we do a pretty good job in
the context we have but there's no doubt
and you'll see this very much in the
media chapter that's something I'm
working through there is that I think
it's become the incentives of the media
right now are to be very polarizing um
to be very blunt this struggle of Fox is
to keep it from becoming more polarizing
not to get it there like where Twitter
wants to pull you is way to the left or
way to the right and it's a it's a
constant fight to keep people you know
cueing to an open process and making
sure our reporters are talking to people
they don't agree with and and so on and
so forth
well good this leads exactly into what
what I promise will be the final
question you you raised the
consideration that the word polarization
has this negative valence it sounds bad
but maybe it's not always bad maybe
there's some interest in having it there
but on the other and I agree with that
but there is certainly a cost right and
if nothing else at the personal level
right that the amount of anxiety induced
by talking to people on the other side
of the aisle seems to me to be much
higher now even in our families or in
our neighborhoods than it was 10 years
ago and part of that is trumpet I don't
think that it's his fault I think that
it is a bigger thing I mean is there is
there some worry that there's a social
fabric issue that you know we can't get
along all we can do is fight the other
side and see who wins yeah I think
there's every reason to worry about that
I don't think at this juncture it has
gotten so bad that I am deeply worried
about our social fabric over the long
term Trump has definitely made this you
know in my view a lot worse but as I
saying earlier in the 60s I think our
social fabric was coming apart in a much
more profound way and I would also argue
that one thing about polarization is
that the alternative to polarization is
often suppression what was very
polarizing in the 60s was that a lot of
disagreements that have been bottled up
were forced into the open like say over
civil rights and dixiecrats for a long
time kept consideration of civil rights
and anti lynching bills off of the floor
of the House or Senate and so that
debate was suppressed when they lost the
power to do that we began having the
debate and it led to a sharp
polarization in the country so one I
think it is okay to have difficult
debates I think the thing where people
feel they have trouble talking about
politics with their families also
sometimes reflects that they become
unused to having political disagreement
because we sort into places and and hang
out with people who tend to think a lot
like us it's pretty for very into
politics and so sometimes it's like only
around that Thanksgiving table that you
hang out with people who you both love
and have to talk to every year but who
really think differently than you do and
sometimes having people just need to
toughen up a little bit about that that
said there's no doubt that I think
polarization is tough on a society and I
think this is really important it is
making it quite impossible to govern
it's very like in a country where what
you need to do is win the house and then
when sent it with its supermajority
filibuster requirement for most bills
and get the President on board and
depending on how you want to look at it
have a favorable ruling from the Supreme
Court
yeah like polarization with that many
veto points and many many many inside
that that I didn't mention what
polarization tends to do is increase
paralysis and I think one thing that
makes these fights harder and worse is
that people are frustrated by their
problems not actually being solved and
while they may not love the way the
other party would solve them I actually
could be better if parties were able to
govern if their majority agendas they
were just kind of able to pass him and
then people could evaluate the outcomes
of that but absent the ability of
parties to actually govern you're just
caught in this endless struggle for
power
you never quite achieve to enact a
governing agenda you never quite able to
enact such that the American people can
ever really judge you based on what did
or didn't happen and so yeah
polarization interacts very badly and
very dangerously with our system in
particular parliamentary systems if you
can elect it you can govern in our
system there's nothing like that
guarantee and so I'm very worried about
polarization but the particular
distinction I make is that I think a lot
of people will listen to an analysis
like that and say well we got to bring
down polarization and for reasons I try
to show in the book I don't think it's
gonna happen I mean I think the feedback
loops it is kicked off are very hard to
stop and very unlikely to change but
what I do think is possible as you could
imagine if we wanted to a political
system that worked better amidst
polarization some of that could just be
bomb proofing against the worst possible
outcomes like there's no reason we
should have a debt ceiling at all such a
great trigger of global financial crisis
for no reason let's just not do that as
other countries don't do that and not
create the possibility for one side or
the other to trigger a huge financial
catastrophe but you could also imagine
getting rid of the filibuster you can
imagine it forms a proportional
representation that would lead to
multi-party systems which could have
some good effects on this I think it'd
be good for DC in Puerto Rico to be
States I mean I would in many ways
restructure American politics quite
radically given a magic wand but for all
the reasons I just said about
polarization making it hard to do
anything makes it very hard to systemic
lis change the nature of the American
political system so I don't have a ton
of optimism that my agenda that was
going to get followed no but we need a
the the rule here at mindscape is we end
on the optimistic note so the optimistic
note and your Paula your podcast works
very differently there yes but there is
an optimistic note there and I like the
idea that the impossible sounding task
of reducing polarization isn't the task
we should be devoted to it's working in
a environment where there is
polarization and nevertheless having a
functioning govern and part of that I
mean maybe you didn't say it out loud
but we also have to work to guarantee
the rights of the tinier party right
like that is what the our government
mental system was meant to do and it's
gone a little bit too far but I think
that if that's where we focus our
efforts
we can make things better that seems
like a good optimistic note to end on
all right the book is called why we're
polarized how I managed to write a whole
book without including a subtitle
as for Kline thanks very much for being
on the mindscape podcast Thank You Sean
[Music]
you
[Music]